[Music]
hello and welcome to the session
for your own good with me marianne c
cart and
a great panel who i will introduce in a
minute
now we're all familiar with the
hippocratic famous line do no harm
fewer know perhaps the more important
line above all
i must not play it god but with life
spans increasing often long past the
point of comfort
it's not unusual for treatments to cause
more suffering mental as well as
physical
than the disease itself so some argue
that doctors have forgotten the promises
they made at medical school
should they recognize that they are
sacrificing well-being
in the name of longevity and pledge to
return to the original values of do no
harm
or is this a dangerous and misguided
strategy that threatens the life and
well-being of us all
well here to debate this are henry marsh
who is one of the uk's leading
neurosurgeons
and author of the best-selling memoir
called do no harm
sarah wooten is the chief executive of
dignity and dying
and co-author of a new book called last
rites
ghts on the subject of care at the end
of life
and natasha vita moore is an author
strategic designer and scientist
working in the fields of human
enhancement technology and life
extension
so as usual i'm going to ask each of
them to do a three-minute pitch to us
all
uh on the subject are doctors
sacrificing well-being
for the sake of longevity and first of
all sarah sarah wooten
imagine having to say goodbye to your
dying daughter seven times
fiona strong was 31 and she had a rare
cancer that had started in her sinuses
and invaded her brain and her nose
by 2018 it was also in her neck shoulder
and spine the tumor was growing and
fiona was finding it difficult to
swallow
and to breathe so the hospice offered to
sedate her
so she wouldn't be aware of her symptoms
when she died
but instead of dying peacefully in her
sleep fiona woke up
just 20 minutes later confused
scared and in pain
she underwent five days of continual
waking and pain before she died
each time her mother would say another
last goodbye to her daughter
but it was only after seven farewells
that fiona eventually died
the blanket ban on assisted dying denied
fiona the option of shortening what
anybody would agree
was a horrendous death and i argue that
nowhere
is the tension between doctor knows best
paternalism
and patient choice more evident and
actually more harmful
than at the end of life doctors are
undoubtedly undoubtedly sacrificing the
well-being
of dying people but not necessarily for
the sake of longevity
fiona's care team absolutely recognized
that her needlessly drawn out death
was not in anybody's best interests the
hospice nurses were crying too
throughout those five days it was
because of a lack of better options
and clinging to the old ways of doing
things
i believe that medical practice should
react to the attitudes and values of
society rather than waiting for the
notoriously conservative medical
profession
to evolve remember doctors objected to
the nhs
they objected to the contraceptive pill
and they objected to the
decriminalization of abortion
some doctors even objected to providing
pain relief in
childbirth in last rites
we argue that there are parallels
between the campaign for assisted dying
and other progressive social campaigns
like votes for women like racial justice
and equal marriage
people have had to fight against a
stubborn stubborn establishment which
refuses to listen
that's not how it has to be 150 million
people have access to your sister dying
now
across the u.s australia and canada and
soon to be new zealand probably
over 80 percent of people in the uk want
the law to change here
it is proven to work the recent
cumberland
report on medical devices and their
safety is a sad reminder
of how women have been harmed by a
medical culture that's been all too
willing
to ignore belittle and gaslight them
any similar review of choice at the end
of life in the future will find that
this country has persisted with a
blanket ban on sister dying for
far too long and that a broken status
quo was propped up by an establishment
which doctors yes are part of that
willingly allowed a vocal minority to
ignore evidence
and override the expressed will of dying
people we shouldn't have to wait for
such a review to tell us what we know
now
not when the status quo inflicts so much
harm on people
like fiona and their families
sarah thank you very much henry marsh
you're part of the medical establishment
what's your pitch
um my book was called do no harm because
of course it's an ironical
title because the practice of medicine
of modern medicine
inevitably involves harm either the risk
of harm
and treatment failing or harm which is
needed to get a good result
and the decision-making is is very
difficult
um it's not as simple
a question of adding up the equations
and saying well if we do this
there's a chance of that happening and
if we don't etc etc
instead you have to balance the risks of
treatment
against the possible benefits and often
we don't know this is about
probabilities there is clear clearly
particularly in america
there is excessive treatment going on
particularly chemotherapy
for cancer we know that in america
now a very very significant part of
people's lifetime
medical expenses are spent in the last
few months of their life in other words
it's wasted but it's not this is not
just
because of doctors being inhuman
insensitive
it is also because as human beings we
are very reluctant to
stop hooping and if you have a drug
where there's a
five percent chance it will prolong your
life
um we all will hope and think we'll be
one of the five percent lucky ones
and forget the 95 chance of failure and
miserable
side effects so it's really a sort of
foliar dirt
between doctors and patients often which
results in
so much over treatment because life
without hope
is very difficult a very good friend of
mine has just been diagnosed with a
highly malignant
brain tumor and i wasn't involved in his
treatment
and because it's my own specialty i
inevitably got involved with him and his
family
and i he's going to have treatment he's
my age
in fact the statistics are the value of
radiotherapy and a man his age with a
height of an english inoperable brain
tumor
yes it really is nothing probably
and yet it's very difficult to say no i
mean the
doctors treating him have recommended it
he has gone wrong with that
um and i face the problem should i tell
him well in my opinion
it's not worth it what would i say if it
was me
and of course that again brings me back
to the fact there's a great quote from
the hospital that neither the deaf
nor son can be looked at steadily we do
find it very very difficult
to think about our own death i had to
tell my friend you've only got a few
months left to live
the next few weeks are the best few
weeks left in your life
of that there's no doubt um
and yet it's so difficult having said
that though i do feel very strongly that
the i suspect a minority of
many palliative care doctors in this
country was so
opposed to assisted dying i regarded as
highly patronizing the sister dying
is not about licensing doctors to kill
people is about patient autonomy and
about allowing us as patients to decide
how we want to end our lives having said
that it is very difficult
and we know from the experience in
oregon that people with a terminal
diagnosis
of six months express an interest in
assisted dying when they go into
palliative care
but often don't take up that option
towards the end
and i know several families medical
families
colleagues of mine whose parents were
doctors who said to their children
you know don't i don't want to die like
this i'd
help me bring it to an end but when the
end did come in fact they wouldn't talk
about it and they developed a sort of
split consciousness many of us do
develop when we're dying
part of us thinks we're going to go and
living forever part of us means we're
dying
so it is it's very difficult but there's
no question about the law in this
country is wrong
and should be changed okay
natasha vitamin you're in america what
do you think
thank you marianne lovely to be here i'd
like to make a couple of basic points
uh the dictum do no harm is a latin
phrase that stems from the
the greek hypocritical oath but we have
to remember that that oath was written
in the fifth century
during a time when very little was known
about biology
genetics and the human genome so we not
only did not see into the body into
genomics into proteinomics into all the
different layers
of the worker bees inside the body
continually working
in a symphony to keep the body healthy
and alive
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas